up to 30,000 people in Southern
California were ordered to leave their
home instead of that in the head of that
Pacific storm rather the two major
evacuation zones in Santa Barbara County
cover a 23 mile area that includes the
mountains near Montecito where mudslides
killed 21 people in January many home
and businesses that spent weeks digging
out after our bracing now for the
possibility it could happen all over
again
sheriff's deputies went door-to-door
yesterday to make sure people followed
evacuation orders well it's been a
chaotic week at the White House and it's
ending with more mixed signals on major
policy issues the NRA suggested
overnight that President Trump may now
be walking back his comments about
stricter gun laws those remarks left
Republicans reeling yesterday many were
also stunned by the president surprise
announcement on steel and aluminum
tariffs which then sent global stock
markets tumbling major Garrett is in the
White House now with the latest on all
of these stories major good morning good
morning president Trump's position on
gun control has been evolving and
evolving in public leaning in toward gun
restrictions earlier this week and then
last night something of an intervention
as top officials the National Rifle
Association met here at the White House
with the president subsequent tweets
then indicated both sides were back on
the same page President Trump gave gun
control advocates hope when he said this
on Wednesday you have to look at the age
of 21 for certain types of weapons take
the guns first go through due process
second but last night the NRA said mr.
Trump wanted the opposite following an
oval office meeting NRA executive
lobbyist Chris Cox tweeted that mr.
Trump and vice-president pence quote
supports strong due process and don't
want gun control
an hour later mr. Trump tweeted that the
meeting went great destroys our
companies and our jobs yesterday mr.
Trump also made a surprise announcement
detailing new tariffs on steel and
aluminum imports you will have
protection for the first time in a long
while and you got to regrow your
industries the tariffs 25% on steel and
10% on aluminum prompted fears of a
costly trade showdown with
and other us trading partners that sent
the Dow plunging more than 400 points
Republicans slammed the move Nebraska's
Ben Sasse said quote you'd expect a
policy this bad from a leftist
administration not a supposedly
Republican one Senate Finance Committee
Chairman Orrin Hatch a top GOP voice on
trade called it a blunder
whoever advised him on this is president
Trump's advisors have been the subject
of scrutiny this week presidential
confidant hope Hicks announced her
resignation and senior advisor Jared
Kushner's business dealings are raising
concerns about potential conflicts of
interest during a nostalgic visit to the
Department of Homeland Security chief of
staff John Kelly the man in charge of
keeping the White House in line jokingly
suggested he was cursed I did something
wrong and God punished me again sources
tell us that comet infuriated the
president and there is also word from
our sources that the National Security
Adviser HR McMaster long the subject of
rumors of his ouster may in fact now be
in real jeopardy though through a
spokesperson the president called
reports of McMasters imminent departure
fake news John Major thanks sounds like
there's a little chaos there in the
briefing room this morning you know
what's interesting about this is this is
not just questions of White House
propriety there is actually the
operation of the White House when you
have the chief of staff making that kind
of joke HR McMaster on the way out
uncertainty on gun policy steel tariffs
surprising part of the administration
this is the basic task of a White House
and it's still disordered this long into
the administration this all happened in
one week that's right it's chaos story
yeah in our executive branch and and
that was okay at the beginning but now
it accumulates it makes it very hard to
run the railroad